-Hey, Doc?
-Mm-hmm?
-I know it's Thursday,
but I was thinking tonight
could be a-a good night
for sex night possibly.
-Ooh.
It's an interesting idea,
but, you know...
Thursdays.
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Anne Hathaway,
everybody!
That was a clip
from "She Came to Me."
And you --
Your wonderful co-star,
Peter Dinklage, he plays --
what would you call it --
opera composer?
-Yes.
-He plays an opera composer
who is on year five
of an artistic blockage.
-Gotcha.
And you play a therapist?
-I was his therapist.
-Okay.
-And then we got married.
-Oh, that's always good.
-They say that you should
definitely do that.
-And one day,
I'm feeling a little --
I'm feeling like I need
a little bit of space from him.
And so I send him off on a walk,
and I tell him
to interact with a stranger,
and he winds up
meeting Marisa Tomei,
who's a tugboat captain,
and she takes him
back to her tugboat
where she reveals to him
while disrobing
that she is
a sex and love addict.
-Oh, wow.
-Yes.
-So never tell your spouse
to take a walk.
You never know --
never know what might happen.
-Well, just when you feel
really sorry for my character,
because she is successful
in seducing him,
you realize that I am
actually in a secret
relationship with God.
-Oh! Well, there you go!
It's so what I love
about indie movies.
[ Laughter ]
Did you enjoy
playing a therapist?
-I did.
I did enjoy playing a therapist.
I was really nervous
about, like,
you know,
just getting it right
and making sure --
it can be quite serious.
But yeah, yeah, it felt like
I could put a lot of things
I have learned to use.
-Yeah, that would be my fear,
if I ever played a therapist,
is that one of mine would go,
"Is that me?"
You had a really a cool thing,
which is --
Again, we mentioned
that you're a producer.
One of the things
you have to do is reach out,
try to find people
to help you with your movie.
For the soundtrack,
you had somebody write a song.
-Yes, yes, yes. Rebecca was the
one that reached out to him.
But our title song,
the end-credits song,
is written by Bruce Springsteen.
-That's really incredible.
-I know!
-And the day you find out
that he's gonna do it,
it just must be --
What a celebration.
-I mean, it was kind of one of
those moments that was so cool.
You expect, like,
everything to explode,
but instead it goes quiet.
You know what I mean?
Like, it's so --
it's so impossible to imagine.
He's -- Yeah, he's so mythic
in his -- in his way.
-Yes. And very sage.
When you actually talk to him,
he seems to have
a very deep wisdom
that not a lot of people have.
-Oh. my gosh. I couldn't.
I couldn't talk to him.
I couldn't possibly do it.
-Yeah, the first time I met him,
he did music
my first year on "SNL."
And I just had to do that thing,
which is I had to just --
I had to say a thing to him
that he's heard a hundred times
and just walk over and be like,
"Hey, I just want to say..."
And he was like, "Cool. How's
the show gonna be this week?"
And I just like, "Uh..."
And just walked away.
I was like, "Oh, I'm not ready
to have, like,
a back-and-forth here.
This isn't a conversation.
This is me unburdening and
running away as fast as I can."
-I just also love the way
you so casually just said,
"Yeah, Bruce Springsteen
was the musical guest
the first week
that I was on 'SNL.'"
Like, you just dropped that
so casually.
Do you ever hear yourself?
-It was my second season.
He was the first.
-Oh, it was your second.
Okay. Got it. Got it. Got it.
-I don't remember
all of the musical guests,
but I remember that,
and I remember The Killers
'cause they're still on the lam.
[ Laughter ]
You've had time on.
I know you love Broadway.
You are a theater kid,
through and through.
-It's true. It's true.
-Have you managed to see stuff
during this downtime?
-Oh!
I saw -- A few months ago now,
but I saw my wonderful friend
Jessica Chastain,
like, levitate on stage
in "A Doll's House."
Did anybody here get to see it?
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Gasps ]
It's like nothing
I've ever seen.
She was -- She was -- I mean,
just -- She was everything.
And then it's so cool
that David Byr--
I mean, for so many reasons
it's so cool that
David Byrne is here,
but I can't wait
to see "Here Lies Love."
I got to see it at the Public.
-Oh, my gosh.
-During the first run of it.
And so I'm so excited to go see
it, just as soon as we're done.
-Alright. Well, I am
so happy to have you here.
It's always just such a delight
to see you.
Congratulations on the film.
-Thank you so much.
-And we always want you
to come back.
Anne Hathaway. "She Came to Me"
is in theaters October 6th.
Stick around. We'll be
right back with David Byrne.